I just saw a picture of you in a bikini
in Jamaica your body is so beautiful you
are very kind no I really I was like you
are it was a thirst trap photo if I've
ever seen it I think it was beyond the
third strap it was it was I made me
think inappropriate thoughts I but but I
was like well you know what if you
looked that good in a bikini yes you're
like in a full water setting angles and
lighting did you see the video of me
trying to make the video
there's a video of me trying to take
that picture because I usually do these
first dip videos where I like dive in
the pool and like I have the little
selfie camera set up and I'm like oh
this is me getting in the water for the
first time I got in the water in the
lagoon and I thought something was gonna
eat me and I literally was like a horror
film yeah I thought this was gonna be
like the last video of the phone like
left on the side of the thing and like
I've been taken away by some sort of
Creature from the Lagoon